welcome to this video playing step by
step with black let's see I've play them
number of times always form interesting
positions okay let's switch variations
and go for the g5 line I don't know that
very well push up a six to come which g3
you can also do that and I really don't
know that no this variation I'm um I
always wanted to study it but never got
around to do it actually guindy seven
maybe okay can you place you five and
rook c8 or maybe don't really know
trying to to use the the good
development on 95 okay but I have two
should be seven
oopsie 8-10 95 and c6 maybe my but it
does not does not seem to be that that
problematic okay my day six now this is
probably not good but I can take him
then maybe queen to be five that that
could be could be okay setting up some
some counter play against the beep on in
the long run I also wanted to get out of
this 94 business nid five business sorry
not 94 okay
can I can think of Bishop to g5 or
Bishop to you form then we'll be ain
interesting maybe he wants 92 to see for
him okay looking looking at the to pawn
hmm should be fun maybe this in 95 now
depending on this answer of course 95
yeah maybe trying to to improve my my
pieces here but it's not good that I
cannot go walk v8 this would be nice
getting the rook on the B file but here
i think i can maybe just take a fall
play the other Knight to f6 okay hmm
take you five wicket you can take your
phone then
if night see for them smites I'm a
pretty active
oh that's that's a that's a very ugly
pin I wanted to play Knight f4 but this
this is really really leavin me very
awkwardly pinned once you form mmm poor
that's not good not at all
ah that's that's terrible really mmm
maybe have to play this and this is
really bad I can just play Quincy 3 or
anything I mean it's really not good
maybe that I can run back yeah okay fine
my move the rock i mean my rook sir I
both detect okay if I knew the paw 95
that's yeah I was I was fearing that
might be six
Oh Jim
just a poem down with a bet with a bad
position and he's got a gun in a tick
her on top of all
yeah it's very bad maybe I should have
now came it's it's just them it's bed
with Queens on and with Queens off it's
also bad the endgame is bad and the
middle games well I can just take it
play Bishop c3 and have a winning end
game
take him yeah still okay I can't be one
he's got to be one of course time
warning
yeah Roxy 597 is at least store I think
this can be played okay I'm still worse
but I'm not immediately losing any more
oh you can thank you yeah this is well
this is well okay could you say get the
knife down check
now I can't fight at least I can fight
him a bit check check check check
I have a napalm
just some way to there's no way to find
us I thought that he would buy one
freaking tempo he's winning this is this
great check check check 1 10 / yeah okay
yeah I mean it was worse the whole way
so it's a deserved loss but still it was
just one tempo and he let me off the
hook here number of times the even was
made on Quincy itís check my schedule
okay yeah it was that was clear so this
was really a really a bad misstep night
see form I can still play 96cm but the
whole thing here here black is totally
fine I have to be porn as a counter play
and a half good pieces so there's
nothing a channel been happening but I
really relied on all night see for him
and played this quickly and after Queen
d3 this this pin is very awkward I was
beforehand I was always thinking I can
take but I'm losing this piece simply so
this is a bad position right here it's
totally okay I can can play many moves
computer wants to go here now I can also
play this like 90 m I just have good
pieces it's nothing nothing to worry
about yeah and then this is just very
awkward it's just various degrees of bed
and he did a good job here this is this
is totally winning and there were some
ways to improve even but okay here the
comp gives Bishop e7 then Bishop b5 and
this is probably also mating attack
yeah okay it was impossible to recover
from 94 okay thanks for watching